well the uncommons is a new center for
work Fitness shopping and food the
perfect place for Las Vegas's second
Earth Cafe Rocky is there live to show
us the drinks the food and the Vibes hi
Rocky how's it going out there
Mercedes Jillian I I know you both know
how much I love Earth Cafe and I'm so
excited to say that there is a new one
here at the uncommon in the southwest
area it's a brand new shopping center
it's beautiful over here and I also
learned today that Earth Cafe and I have
something in common we were both
established in 1989. so Bobby Leon you
guys are the owners of this location
just kind of introduce people to Earth
Cafe and and what this place is well yes
Earth Cafe started in 1989 by Shalom and
Gila Berkman one day they decided to go
to Peru and they met with a coffee
grower by the name of George and from
there they got you know educated about
heirloom coffee beans they got educated
by the deforestation and so forth so
they love this Mission and they wanted
to continue his mission here in the U.S
well we are so thankful to them let's
move over to you Leon explain that
heirloom coffee concept and and this is
actually a really special establishment
because it's the first of its kind in
America
that's correct um originally so Earth
Cafe was one of the original
um uh cafes to offer heirloom coffee and
a lot of people ask us what is heirloom
coffee so heirloom coffee comes from a
rare variety of coffee tree that has
never been genetically modified it
really creates the most uh acid-free
elegant tasting coffee with a very very
smooth flavor profile wow that is
beautiful and let's name some things
that are on your famous famous menu I
know right here we have a very special
drink it's matcha but also has some
espresso in it right right Lance come
see this one over here this is this is a
good one it's uh it's a rising sun it's
uh well we kind of nickname our our
energy drink so if you're looking for a
morning pick me up or afternoon pick me
up or uh that's the drink for you
I saved my coffee for today for this for
this segment just for you guys because I
knew I was gonna want some
um now this is the second location here
in Las Vegas why did you guys choose to
bring it to this area well in Commons is
a new development here it's basically
like a mixed use there's offices there's
going to be a lot of residential in the
area there's like specialty retails here
one-of-a-kind retailers so we felt like
this was the right place to be in in the
proper you know tenant mix to be in and
we so far we've been very happy okay
well this place is about to get really
popular they've been open for about two
weeks now so come on down and check it
out before the Lions get crazy and are
out the door I'm coming up we're going
to talk about the food menu because it
is just as good as the drink menu thank
you Rocky those drinks look too pretty
to drink oh I love Earth Cafe so